going to turn now to it only on CBS
mornings a conversation with Samantha
power administrator of the U.S agency
for International Development she joins
us now with the latest on the American
response to this disaster administrator
power thank you for being here what are
the top priorities in the rescue and now
to be honest right a recovery effort
going on in turkey and Syria
well Linda Thomas Greenfield our U.N
Ambassador is introducing has introduced
a resolution in New York
demanding that more border crossings
into Northern Syria be opened Syria of
course has had a much more challenging
time you have the Assad regime in one
part of the country opposition held
territory in another part of the country
and the Russian Federation for a very
long time has insisted that there be
only one Border Crossing into Northern
Syria and we are trying to have that
expanded to three border crossings that
will mean the kind of industrial scale
of flow of humanitarian assistance to
Syria where the rescue effort hasn't had
the resources of that in Turkey
now the U.S has announced that it's
going to provide 85 million dollars
Samantha and humanitarian Aid to Syria
and to Turkey exactly how will that
money be used
well it's a combination first of all
it's very important to stress that it'll
be spent in in both countries in turkey
and Syria uh for now of course it's it's
funding that will go to the search and
rescue effort the U.S has a 200 person
Disaster Response Team on the ground
including search and rescue with about
170 000 pounds of equipment doing search
and rescue now and what will be recovery
recovery means the world as well to
families making sure that loved ones are
retrieved and can be properly buried but
as you know it's freezing there and now
you have uh you know that tens of
thousands of buildings that no longer
stand and people need temporary housing
they need water and hygiene they're not
going to have their livelihoods access
to livelihoods anytime soon so just
basic food Staples this is just our
initial response and we really need both
private citizens businesses and other
countries to step up at scale
Madam administrator you used to be the
U.S ambassador to the U.N and the U.N
recently called the international
response in Syria a failure do you agree
with that and and why
well I think we've seen Again The
Compassion of the world congregate in
turkey
and many many people are alive today and
will recover from this earthquake
because of the international response
what has been challenging again is that
the Russian Federation through the
security Council has blocked uh proper
humanitarian response in Northern Syria
and that's just another sign of Russian
brutality or coldness to human life but
that really is what the UN is talking
about is let us get the response in
Syria up to what it is in Turkey let us
have that humanitarian Aid flowing to
all the places it is needed and not just
the places uh you know where the
Sovereign government is able to manage
the responses in Turkey
administrative power millions of
Americans have been moved by the
pictures coming out of turkey and and
Syria and they want to help how would
you recommend they do so
well first it's overwhelming for us to
see the level of generosity it's not
surprising we've seen it on Ukraine we
see it whenever a domestic emergency
hits but we have an organization that
we've set up that it gives you a listing
of really credible very effective
organizations to to give money to it's
cidi.org
c-i-d-i.org and one of the things I want
to stress is the Temptation is to give
blankets and teddy bears and strollers
and and you know Goods but actually what
the organizations on the ground most
need is money is Cash because they can
buy locally that can actually help
communities recover get markets going
again so if if you have the resources to
be able to give even a little cash is
best
administrative power we want to help
thank you for your time this morning in
helping us understand more
thank you